Mi nombre es Noémie tengo 32 años y
Soy criador de cerdos en el Gers.
[Música]
es mejor que anoche
la realidad de la profesión ya ahora yo
soy independiente cual no era el
caso antes de entonces ¿qué hará mi
horarios seran los animales
necesidades de los animales las necesidades de
mercado de clientes de baños
cortando es decir de otros criadores
pero aún queda
dueña de mis propias decisiones y
Siento que puedo hacer mucho
Ya no elijo según mi ética.
y lo que quiero hacer
detrás
[Música]
Me gradué de Sciences Po en
asuntos públicos en 2014 y luego
Empecé a trabajar en Hong Kong.
Londres y allí tuve después
varios años de problemas de salud que
significó que tuve que dejar el grande
ciudad e ir al campo y
De hecho, fue bastante obvio cuando
Empecé a poner mis manos de nuevo
la tierra y en el trabajo del animal
y desde el campo me dije que
eso es lo que quería hacer con mi
vida
[Música]
Me dije a mí mismo que quería
contribuir a algo
más pero en ningún caso continuar
apoyar un sistema que ponga
pesticidas de disruptores
endocrinos y contaminantes en nuestro
medio ambiente
[Música]
Me di cuenta de que mi
combustible era humano y yo
Preferí dirigir claramente mi
busca lugares donde
iba a estar en la agricultura colectiva y
Creo que también corresponde a un
aspiración de nuestra generación no
querer encontrarse solo y aislado en
campo abierto porque eres sumiso
con mal tiempo estás expuesto a peligros
del clima a veces pasan cosas
con tus animales o tus cultivos que
Van a ser difíciles de usar, así que vale la pena.
mejor que sean varios en las camadas y yo
piensa que la agricultura del mañana será
colectivo o no será
[Música]